يتحدث سيدريك إلينا قليلاً عن
هذه المناطق الأربع ، ما الذي تعنيه الأحكام العرفية
بالنسبة لهم وبالنسبة للمدنيين الذين
يعيشون هناك ، نعم صباح الخير بريانا
، فهذه المناطق الأربع التي نتحدث عنها هنا هي كارسون زابوريزا دونيتسك ولوهانسك.  أن
الروس احتلوا منذ
بداية أه هذه المرحلة الأخيرة من الحرب ،
فماذا تعني الأحكام العرفية فعليًا
للناس هناك بشكل جيد هو في الأساس
استبدال السلطة العسكرية
بالحكم المدني وهذا يعني أن جميع
القوانين القائمة سلطة مدنية
وإدارة  تم تعليق العدالة
بالطريقة العادية ، حيث
يتمتع القائد العسكري بسلطة غير محدودة
لوضع القوانين وإنفاذها ، وهذا يعني أنه
يمكنهم بالفعل السيطرة على هذه الأشياء
في هذه المناطق الآن ، وقد أعلنت أوكرانيا أيضًا
الأحكام العرفية في الماضي في الواقع
في نوفمبر من عام 2018
المشرعين الأوكرانيين  كانت قد سنت هذا عندما
استولى الروس على سفن البحرية الأوكرانية
وبالطبع في فبراير عندما
تم غزو أوكرانيا  أدخل إيدنت الأحكام
العرفية بعد إعلان الغزو
وما إعلان بوتين
يكشف لك عما تحاول روسيا
هنا ،
لذا في هذه الحالة بالذات ما
نحاول السيطرة على هذه المنطقة ، لذلك
علينا أن نضع في اعتبارنا ما يجري في
ساحة المعركة  هذه هي نفسها شمس العناية
هنا ، فهذه المدينة هي المكان الذي
يتحرك فيه الأوكرانيون بهذه
الطريقة وربما بهذه الطريقة لمحاولة
استعادة هذه المنطقة عندما يفعلون ذلك
، وإذا نجحوا في
ذلك ، فسيؤدي ذلك إلى إجبار المدنيين على الخروج من
هذه المنطقة لأن  سوف يقوم الروس
بإجلائهم قسرًا ويمكنهم
القيام بذلك بموجب أحكام الأحكام
العرفية لهذا القانون العرفي والمرسوم
الذي قدموه الآن
وسيدريك ليس فقط في هذه
المناطق التي تم ضمها بشكل غير قانوني ، نرى أمن
تيتان صحيح نحن  فهم أن هذا
يحدث أيضًا داخل روسيا ، حيث يقوم بوتين
بتشديد الأمن هناك ، ما نوع
السلطة التي يمنحها المسؤولون المحليون
في روسيا من بين أمور أخرى  الأشياء Brianna
ما يفعله هو أنه يسمح لهم
بالتحكم في حركة الأشخاص يمكنهم
التحكم في حركة الأشخاص داخل
وخارج المناطق وعلى وجه التحديد
إذا نظرت هنا ، فهذه هي المناطق الحدودية
في هذه المنطقة وهي
تؤثر أيضًا على الحدود  إلى كازاخستان
والحدود إلى المناطق الجنوبية مثل
جورجيا وأذربيجان في تلك
البلدان ، لذا فهم يتحكمون في
الحركة ، فهم يخلقون وضعاً
يمكنهم فيه السيطرة فعليًا على
المعارضة ويحاولون في الأساس
تقييد حركة السكان و
قدرة السكان على معارضة
الحرب